according to
hello everybody welcome to pray what's
up sup not much uh I'm John Luke he's
Jake
we have pray we're gonna play pray yes
so we're gonna start we're gonna start
right f well kind of right before where
the demo and so the demo ends by you
watching this video and you can't even
slow the area a bit we're gonna watch
this video and then we'll jump in start
exploring we're gonna pick up the
shotgun and then try to do some stuff
that you hopefully didn't see in the
demo yes I am going to be monitoring
chat so feel free to ask any questions
Jake is playing on the ps4 for anyone
wondering which just if you have the
option play on PC I think that I think
we kind of figured in the office that
might be the best way to play just
because the aiming I definitely prefer
it on PC V I'm talking about the
movement of the enemies is so fast and
requires I feeling a level of precision
that the mouse's feels pretty good way
first thing and I found pretty as you
can change clunky it's an op yeah the
controller there's a back of the view
and me it knows what you've forgotten
we've been testing a new kind of neuro
mod based on the type of organisms
mapping their neural patterns onto ours
problem is and said if I bash this after
the video there's something behind it
yes oh if you look to the right to the
right or get our sorry the left there
supposed to be a prize no no no like of
the video speed between test runs you
can see a code and that's for that safe
in that room if you head back to them oh
I saw that erased yeah that's pretty
cool
yeah that's exactly what Alex did well
I'll just go back there now why you're
not going to like what I have to say
next on I like write that down
is it a five one five one five one fifty
I'm just gonna make a note that's fifty
one fifty and I'll probably forget what
it is and never do it air skating wants
to know what is the general story of
this game so not fully clears yet so the
the basic premise seems to be that you
are on a space station that is full of
these aliens referred to as mimics that
can mimic thanks mimic objects and have
been like attacking and killing people
you were in some sort of like simulation
that was kind of like faking you being
in like your apartment but in reality
you're on a space station you're trying
to kind of figure out what's going on
from there a lot of mystery a lot a lot
of intrigue the game seems to be doling
out the story to slow pace although if
you're like me and you read a lot of
these emails and stuff like that you
could already kind of start to piece
together it sort of implies that you
weren't necessarily fully tricked into
being like in that apartment that sounds
like maybe you volunteered to do this
and that you like lost your memory this
is really cool I love this offense I
know uh I needed a key card to get any
further the first time to do in the
apartment looked really cool okay I'm
gonna get the shotgun
quickly somebody wants them off the ps4
latency was fixed I assume they're
referring to kind of the swimmy control
would be a little bit better than the
demo I didn't play a whole lot of the
demo but it doesn't seem like it it
seemed alright where do you think it hit
nice did I just like it remake combat
basics
sometimes these pop up I know laughter
I've had the gun for a long time and
it's like you can turn those off in the
menu though if you don't wanted yeah I
see him I see him he's not very good at
hiding
so it says give me PC demo um so
unfortunately we don't have well I do
have a at my PC is a is the game with a
I just got the first neural mod so I'm a
little further back oh speaking of which
I have I haven't used any neuro mods I
figured we would use them here yes and
see kind of maybe what rap we can go
scientist engineer security so I imagine
security is very like unlocking doors
turrets type of the hacking yacking
engineers okay like uh recycling Oh like
like building things do they seems more
territorial tej so security might just
be for unlocking stuff and scientist
medical a lot of medical basically Oh
scientist got hacking is hacking - okay
all right well I don't know then well
increase damage with security weapons -
100 firearms Oh seems good yeah it seems
good it's for though it's expensive
conditioning increase your health 115
and stay I kind of want that he'd
answered latency questions yeah Jake it
seems like the blatant C's kind of the
same from what yeah it seems about the
same okay into a state of combat focused
410 secretary wants to know if any
reviews are out yeah not that I'm aware
of I mean the game just we just got it
yeah we weren't actually supposed to get
it till tomorrow - yeah we got it early
this morning and people the oh here it
is straily I can play Oh God this is
noisy cringe
we ran through some more of those too oh
[ __ ]
some incident sees me I didn't kill that
last that last mimic anyway I've got
more I can do do it I kind of like the
security one combat focus that sounds
kind of cool enter a state of combat
focus for 10 seconds which time slows
around you or stealth enemies take long
didn't it detect you maybe I'll do both
of those so what's to know is this game
fun uh I like so far I'm liking it a lot
yeah and kind of based on what I know
about so yesterday yes yesterday we had
some of the devs in to show off later
parts of the game they said it was going
through the game they were showing off
and some of that stuff looked really
really cool
so if you're kind of want to see more of
like what a later portion of the game
looks like you should definitely check
out that livestream they did we also
have some gameplay we put up with that
as well
that stuff was pretty awesome what they
were doing they did this like really
cool thing where he took a bunch of his
like resources he didn't need and
dropped him on the ground and then I'm
not sure what he's shot but he shot a
thing at them and they all like if this
explosion happened and then they all
like merged together and turn into their
base components and so it was like a
really quick way of recycling them
without a recycler and that's pretty
cool really cool I was like whoa yeah
I've seen some really cool things that
like just from the the developer videos
we've seen they've seems like you can do
so it's like Dishonored in that sense
right where I can experiment play around
with different cool abilities so we're
gonna grab the shotgun and then we'll
move on I'm sure some people are because
I remember doing the demo livestream I
did with Macau a lot of you are
wondering about the shotgun
yeah a lot of you were wondering about
the the PC port for the PC version and
how it runs and I can say that so far in
my 30-minute experience it runs really
really smooth it looks nice I haven't
had any glitches or hitching no
framerate problems at all seems really
good again I'm only thirty minutes and
though I didn't like how it had did you
have much in the way of huge I did not
want to do that this is the slowdown
time thing whoa
so yeah like the the PC version doesn't
have any POV slider or anything like
that no bummer yeah I wish it had more
of those kinds of options there's no way
for me to turn off the HUD I was trying
to find like a headless mode that's
weird
especially arcane - yes honored was
there to handle for that to stuff like
that like yeah turn off the HUD missing
that and I agree that to some degree
actually probably want to keep some
elements of the HUD I feel it's a very
different kind of game but I do like how
your ammo and stuff is integrated in the
gun rather than that's nice yeah okay
we'll continue on these objectives now
that I've gotten that taken care of so
I've peaked in this room I know what's
coming up it's kind of a scary looking
enemy so we'll see how I see how I fare
against it and I think they're still a
mimic whoa oh yeah name it because I
what do you think of the music
there it is none of them do one under
there yeah sure is just naturally do
that oh okay I guess they do
where'd it go
I love just walking into room and you
just start snacking everything like I
son of a [ __ ] I know you're there it's
one of them oh wait was that one knock
down over there before listen that one
ah dang it
he probably turned to something else in
a chair yeah he probably did hmm maybe
you know yeah I'll just keep going well
this Oh actually should take that ooh
yeah that yet I do the Flex the foam I
wonder maybe we can draw it out this is
so that's what it's for is to like do
you can do weird stuff with this thing
oh hi there alright what it oh it's the
phone or that that yeah yeah yeah oh he
dang it oh here goes Jesus oh where did
he go no dang it there is okay oh I'm
not him oh okay Elizabeth do we get him
yeah yeah that was the one I hit a
couple times I actually got confused
this isn't the room where I saw that
deadly thing I'm gonna go back and see
what's in that room there was like a
tough enemy there too I brought that guy
on fire yeah yeah yeah I mean Miguel
trying to fight him in the demo we died
oh you guys we can move on then oh you
can try it it's but we didn't we didn't
go very well we also didn't have much in
the way of ammo
yeah it's down here I have a shotgun
you're a little more prepared than we
are get the area map down here too which
is cool yeah I've definitely so far I've
been trying to play this game without
looking at the map or like turning on it
is because I mean they give me so many
like signs just like that I kind of want
to try like explore on my own at least
so far
who knows maybe not y'all get tired oh
oh I can't see you riding behind the
thing
come here someone asked what we're
playing on we're playing on ps4 so maybe
that Kirkfield Langley Oh got hit
there's one dead I got only got three
bullets left I feel like he's just gonna
hit this I'm gonna [ __ ] explode and
die oh my god
oh my god blu-ray come in room out come
here oh let me come here come on dude
because he's not it's not having it
shooting through the glass
I don't know wasting more ammo oh yeah I
guess I can use my shotgun there's a
little dart gun no nevermind yeah guys
I'm sorry with Midwest boy oh he's
moving now now he's doing it which
directions are gonna go this way
keep God whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa well
there goes that hang it
Oh Oh careful careful there so wants to
know if there's any SLI support not that
I'm aware of
so Stiles are asking about the length of
the game so we heard that Oh
nuke to me it'll take around 15 to 20
hours if you just kind of play through
the game but if you're trying to do like
a 100% see everything it could take
somewhere between 30 to 40 hours dang
that's what we've heard from the devs
but none of us have beaten it so we
cannot say we do know we got a we were
given a little little liquor guide and
with the guide came a bunch of developer
tips oh yeah run this game which we got
oh maybe we want to try that that sounds
really fun all right I'm gonna grab that
shotgun just run up and get through this
area since I was just here
it's back here
got to use my neuro mods again - is
there a ps4 pro support for prey oh I do
not know yeah I don't know either as a
good good question uh I mean that's I
want to say but I mean dishonored - had
it at pro support so you'd think that it
would but again I really don't know who
oh so it eventually just tells you the
key go no I found it whoa I knew it was
a pretending to be that dude yeah whoa
that's cool or no I was the chair he was
under yeah yeah I was probably that I
did see on the tutorial for the stun gun
when I picked it up it said that it
works really well against human enemies
I made the distinction that those were
different from the aliens
yeah um II wonder if you're gonna fight
like crazy humans later or something I
think you probably will all right
I know ignored that room for now and
I'll just move on yeah let's say let's
move on let's check out some new stuff
combat basics I'm going to use these
quickly as well see I felt like from the
demo fixed Jake doesn't seem to notice
too much difference in terms of feel he
said he didn't fly to much of the day
does it feel like does the input lag
feel bad on the controller it doesn't
feel bad it just doesn't it's not as
good as I'd like it to be I guess okay
uh combat focus again that was cool
still
we'll do hacking - stronger faster
bodies at the moment okay there are some
wants to know if this runs on the
CryEngine yeah at the splash screen says
it runs on the CryEngine where there's
only one that time so this is no review
pre-order cancelled but I mean yeah do
you wait for reviews you know uh we just
got the game now I don't think anyone's
gonna have review of this until probably
Monday yeah Monday maybe late Sunday
some pourcel has to come in and order at
that review but yeah I you know if
you're not a hundred percent on it I'd
wait I would I'd wait and see for
yourself
I typically avoid pre-ordering games
anyway yeah I I tend to try and avoid
that too loading screens are long
another reason why I might better play
on PC yeah not not too many issues with
loading times on PC
yeah takes a bit of time not a lot as
long as Sniper Elite though is that the
one Sniper Elite 3 which people were
complaining about because it loading was
really long was it for sniper ghost
Warrior I per goes for your three not
sniper elite
how many guns are in the game oh good
question uh I don't know how many but at
least on the PC you have up to eight uh
hotkey slots that wield Oh looks like it
holds way more than eight things
although that we would have looks like
it also holds your powers powers yes so
not really sure I'm gonna gonna I know
there's a crossbow later yeah
what are you doing well that seems
normal
Oh woah stun it or glue gun it
not excited well that did a number on me
I thought I could just go up and hack it
clearly I could not banana-peel LAN take
you take that's appeals we gonna you can
recycle that stuff
drink all the drinks whoo
I see a drink whoo office been in my way
chair
the best kind yeah all right emails we
got here I like how I think you
mentioned yesterday but I like how you
interact with the computers like this
yeah an or interact with everything it
like doesn't take you out of it
it's like doom 3 yeah it's like the one
thing from doom well I mean I like okay
I like doing free but that was an
element from Doom 3 that I was really
bummed we're kids didn't use like ah
come on it's so cool what is happening
Oh stuff loading can you look to that
telescope I doubt it but you totally can
oh that's cool there is a floating
person can you move hell no I'm stuck
here where's the floating person they're
on the top
next I'll symbol wait what's coming into
view well it's a global thing there's
one thing I really like about dishonored
in this game is you can interact with
pretty much everything yep a lot of
picking up stuff a lot of reading stuff
ooh that you could probably set that on
fire yeah that's that reminds me
Bioshock yeah you'd have liked those
who's all right I wonder if I can hack
this thing cuz I upgraded my stun it
then try and hack it
didn't do anything can you hold that
down yeah you got charging oh this might
be bad oh boy
yeah there you go you can't hack but I
live a Louisville react this is Chuck so
bad like we turned the game audio yes we
can
yeah alright come to up a little bit let
me know if that's good my suit shields
have like completely been destroyed how
to get this back I have no idea open I
only get a chance to show it off he the
desert on cruel subject that dart gun
you can actually use it to not only to
like pushed well doors open but also um
you can actually interact with the
monitors oh really here you could you
could shoot through here bolt your dart
gun yeah I'll do that right now shoot
that yep there it is okay I can't wait I
have my monocle donut alright trying in
area map security controls try and
download the area map from here think
that works Oh little too high oh come on
yeah yeah that's pretty cool awesome
okay I wonder if security controls can
unlock it oh wait I don't even yeah we
didn't even have to do that well you can
play it was worried this do working
upgrade that was rad but yeah so the I
can get them all back as good as that's
really cool yeah the devs are like
showing off cool stuff like that was
like that's rad so yeah like any time
you have like a little hole that you can
maybe shoot through try and see if you
can like in a computer or even like a
button to open a door you can apparently
use that for for cool puzzles like that
that's so cool
alright I opened a security Locker what
happened to the may v livestream I liked
those guys I liked those guys do the
what the robbing Peter oh what happen to
them
yeah what did they play they watched all
the FMV cutscenes of rebel and dark
forces to Jedi Knight and oh boy oops I
was laughing at my desk it was really
funny they should honestly just do a
thing where they watch watch these and
be cutscenes phantom no matching keycard
good I don't want to deal with him
anyway
okay we need to keep car I am NOT gonna
want to pick so I just set off that
alarm so it says I am out the frame
rates are too unbearable I really the
frame rate seems a lot of people seem
really complaining about the frame rates
unless you
it's hour stream you're talking about
but uh it seems fine yeah the frame rate
seems pretty solid yeah I I mean it you
know it's a solid 30 but it's totally
solid 30 like I know issues with it Oh
should we get drunk jean-luc yes does
that do it do you get like wow that's a
the exact sound from Bioshock I like
close to it dearly swimmy
well I drank a lot not much happen you
got a little coat around your head I
feel whoa
you're worried I did drink around three
bottles of champagne and like six beers
so could be why maybe Oh drink bourbon
oh yeah just keep your she's gonna keep
drinking I'm sorry I love about these
kinds of games like a BioShock Infinite
on my out of space uh you would be like
oh I'm dying I'll eat this hotdog out of
this trash can
oh so much better now this moldy hotdog
we got done here
ooh so it's just what level of toughness
are we playing this is normal
there's easy normal and hard I don't
think there's any other two others one
more thoroughly a nightmare beat it
first no it seemed like I could play
unlock it right away
really even see it it was the phantom at
least at least on PC um I'm kind of
curious how yeah how nightmare was
playing okay well you hop up
I think I probably not oh stop it do you
use the try and like plug up those yeah
that's what I need yeah and then just
jump it oh okay yeah what do you got I
don't have any think there anything else
burnt circuit board alright I need it
I'm getting rid of this banana Tory's
face so you could just if you hit
transfer it automatically will move it
over as opposed to like picking it out
thing like uh fighting it yeah wrench
here I have a wrench I don't need a
wrench
Tate trying to give us advice in the
chat too late a can figured it out EMP
so once it all the game is so far seems
pretty good yeah I'm definitely enjoying
it a lot okay that's um blood sir
flashlight there is oh not blood don't
eat it
what are you trying to get over here I
don't know I opened it went in and okay
oh can we get up there their smile why
else would you go yeah that's what
that's a vent well I know I can get up
using good old glue gun I have a
question
all right with the glue gun try shooting
it standing on one jumping up and then
down and then just like propelling
yourself up get like a good base just to
get on first
yeah sometimes they're small I've
noticed that maybe it's like maybe it's
dependent on where I'm standing me like
it was like geometry dang it ah
man oh no okay they can't seem to
connect with each other
dang oh well okay well there you go
that's uh let's hope I can do this yeah
I find the physics a little janky when
you're jumping yeah I turn to jump from
one to Juana's yeah like that like that
it sounds very tiny though I need a
bigger one okay okay hopefully you can
still get up there does not think it
it's a little yeah okay
I need to break this instant
oh so uh oh there's also some on the
floor taze mentioning this spare parts
all right that's good good thing to grab
appreciate it okay this is being
streamed on PC no although we have
played the PC version I was playing it
earlier at my desk and so far it's
pretty good I've had no issues with it
it runs really smooth I think I prefer
playing the game on master keyboard
personally yeah yeah just do like a hot
back and yeah do that
I think that's jeez even on PC I had
trouble with this I think it's just a
little finicky which is yes Wow whoa now
oh you stuck nope you're good I will say
so far at the end we I don't like this
the game is not demanded I've been doing
these platforms it seems like a cool
alternate way to yeah things but you
don't have to do it at least I'll yet
lab equipment special parts requests
prototypes we should be able to fix your
looking-glass terminal from dr.
Calvino's workshop
I love the nods lookingglass how they
call huh huh oh yeah the the tech for I
don't know what yeah it's like it's like
videos that are like yeah it's a good
name and it's good it's a good reference
so I can shoot so wants to know why we
have the game yeah we got review copies
checking it out
get that guy getting quick little sital
last very long whoa
I've noticed you can't you walk
backwards very slow as I guess you
wouldn't realize you can also do a yeah
damn crispy frites I'll just eat it
test-tube samples I will take it I have
one ready
I need a final spots it
when does the review embargo and there
is a review embargo I mean we can we can
talk about the game as much as we want
[Music]
but uh as far as like when we will have
these review up that depends on when our
reviewers two more finishes it we're
thinking I mean I don't want to say but
probably sometime early next week yeah
okay
I really need to find a place to so us
enough you can resume your demo say it
in the whole game apparently no I was
not able to you tried but I deleted the
demo and then downloaded this because I
didn't have space oh maybe if I didn't
delete it I could have but I hear people
say no yeah that's not a thing how far
have you gotten to the game we are just
a little bit past the demo we started
yeah you say
after the dough
I need to get in here
oh this is where we came from oh now go
to the security station I guess we've
activated your phone whoa
oh I should have known that's what I've
been doing that where I'll just kind of
rush through and I'm like oh hey I smell
so like you checking
uh hey GameSpot the main problems I've
heard from players is that of the demo
was that the baby feels clunky that's
how that music could play long after
these enemies were killed but that's the
claim to address these in the full game
since morning and you could confirm so I
can't I haven't noticed the combat music
playing long after I had one moment
where a musical sting played when
nothing happened although okay it turns
out I think there actually wasn't mimic
there and I just didn't notice it so
that was felt a little weird especially
because it was like really loud in my
headphones and I was like ah no I
haven't noticed anything with the combat
music playing as far as the swimmy
controls ago Jake says they feel kind of
about the same not as tight as he'd want
them to be he also didn't play a huge
amount the demo so we're not we haven't
done like a direct that nobody sees this
comparison that my peeve yeah I'm not
that how we can maybe check it out so I
got leverage because so you can move
stuff so you'll move this - it's very
deus ex get in here spare part parts
maybe this will take us into his lab all
right I want to go back and drop off
some like junk I'm hoping there'll be
something in his workshop right a
workshop it sounds like I built it that
ninja got don that's a very interesting
statement however gamestop doesent
review games as far as I'm aware so I'm
not really sure why you're talking what
did you know you didn't do that I did
not do that oh this is where I was
remember that so yeah there's the guy
but they a glue gun new transcript so
when you pick up the weapon it doesn't
like add more ammo it actually gives you
a second weapon yeah okay forget that
grab whatever you can and get to my
office we're evacuating what what should
I do romance exotic material just hurry
you hold triangle to take the ammo oh so
you can take the MA out of it okay cool
cool cool which there we go
good to know I mean nothing else in here
really all right all right
live
all right Clive one if there's any I
love that they're named I know and then
you like you'll find collides like
computer later
Noel fourth live I killed them shotgun
yeah you got fourteen mo do you wanna do
a reload though on it should do a reload
on hope I want to do that yeah hit it
with the UH I think that they got the
Huntress bolt pastor alright we love
that and you load that gonna freeze them
and shock on them there's no quick save
button on a console loser no you have to
press Start and then hit save okay
that's how they did it in a dishonored
dishonored as well which is it is please
listen one more perfect
all right materials fried hard drive oh
here we go
I'm hoping even counter more human
characters to interact with because it
looks like you do I feel like I've seen
trailers or you've like come across like
not settlements but like groups of
people okay okay cuz that but I don't
know definitely my favorite thing about
Bioshock was interacting with like all
the crazy people like Sandra :
yeah always kept like something between
you and the characters that I noticed in
Bioshock yeah you can never directly you
know right yeah it was like a glide
there's like a glass screen dividing you
up I still need to store some my stuff I
think I have to go back to my office
right store this this junk it's like
look how much should I have
suit model maybe I should shut it even
get a suit modification engineer
sumon here we go our son wants to know
are these the aliens from edge of
tomorrow but actually the first time I
saw them I totally thought of the aliens
from edge of tomorrow are they called
that called some kind of similar to that
movie yeah that's a good movie isn't it
doesn't did they change the name though
to live die repeat yeah yeah they did
which is weird that's what they
originally wanted to call it I guess but
they didn't think it would people would
want to is that is that why yeah they
didn't think people would want to see
movie called live die repeat so they use
it as a tagline but since I don't know
when it came on DVD they were like screw
it we can do whatever we want
yeah I don't think it would be sold that
well with the name now it didn't or uh
so I think they changed it to live die
repeat I don't think it's sold that well
either was a decent movie is a good
movie they should have called it by the
original Japanese name because it's
based off of the japanese light novel
which is all you need is kill which is
actually what they called the movie when
they released it in Japan but the
Japanese version that movie is called
all you need is kill which is a great
name yeah okay so
it wants me to keep going back to that
securing station I don't go this way
maybe I'll find a guard or whatever
someone's asking again about Crone
Hanson's I'm gonna take a look
okay so I'm curious myself good idea
whoa someone already has review up as of
two hours ago ah Matt dude how did you
get mmm I don't know about that
who's reviewed at gadgets 360 me
yeah they gave it a 9 out of 10 really
well it trusted then I'm just kidding
yeah I don't know I've read that review
that's crazy to me that they have that
that early that seems old suspects every
time I go into a new room it's like
alright what object in here should I not
trust can't really find anything on it
the pro support crate ok dishonored had
pro support didn't it it did dishonored
a pro support which leads me to believe
they should have pro support but again I
can't yeah I do not know
Beck pro sport came later though didn't
it I think it's because the pro was now
on this honor came out right no no no
the probe was out I think it was right
away okay material yields I love this
kind of like all the attention to detail
this kind of stuff I've been reading all
of the yeah like the whiteboards and I
love that stuff just like recharge yes
that is the baddest a grenade that they
used okay
ballistics chamber released recycler
charge release it yeah
yep turns them in a come on that's
pretty cool open chamber yeah so they
were doing a thing where they had like a
bunch of stuff that it they would just
drop it under the ground
and toss the grenade toss the grenade
well actually I think what they did was
I think they drop the grenade - and then
I think they shot the grenade
okay how they did it so there is a
lesson here control control panel
it's the tutorial okay that's for
repairing if we want to repair it seems
fine now
does it seem broken because I think it
would say if it was but yeah so there's
this we can find find the the code hmm
but I don't to spend too much time
looking for yeah something what's our
other objective right now we got the
workshop yeah oh those that you get the
beginning of the corpse where's that
what the court yeah get bill Andy's key
from his body psychotronics and what I'm
trying to do is use the security station
to discover oh okay it's just the finest
workshop keycard access hardware labs
wonder if I can give you
she shot decent map I like it
did it say get through through the
machine shop hardware labs we're in the
hardware labs this is the hardware lab
area okay okay
yeah I don't know if there's a way we
gotta fight his keycard or I can so it
says the security station help me find
his location oh okay I have to go to
Crewe so we can maybe avoid okay so we
gotta find his location get his keycard
got it yeah
then Calvino
lately the knees on the heart really
look I guess dr. Calvino Lorenzo Calvino
nope
so once enough you can make your own
character no but you can pick the gender
security station crew I wouldn't be
probably being hardware labs oh this
guy's alive normal locate crew member
fine
Oh interesting you could just you just
find okay well let's just find all the
North I'll live people and eventually
we'll find the one that we need is there
anyone alive
oh they check off when you kill them oh
this is this like everyone in the whole
game probably throw a list of like all
the people that's cool
he says we missed it in hardware go bad
where yeah
no no like I'm on the list Oh
five warrants floor enzo calvini okay oh
here it is oh there we go
oh so what have you so hard Hill looks
like it he's in the heart okay dad
Marcus oh wow it's kind of cool wonder
what the in fiction reason for that is
like if you are you go up that um that
thing in the middle this thing yeah hmm
going back down
I'm going back down not kissing I
thought he was I thought he was up there
not doing that okay I know the doctor
was above you he is I wanted to repair
this but it zapped me so well no thanks
okay go up
[Music]
is there anything weird going on over
there
I don't want you to panic
what is going on Langly not sure yet
Security's running all over the place
everyone's still working there I guess I
don't know I've been in the lab all day
hang on I'm looking now I don't trouble
in trouble
so um if you pop the wheel you can
actually doesn't button to just yeah in
one anything yet man
this is kind of game they get be really
easy to get lost in just yeah I'm
forever an Evo right there
scared the [ __ ] out of me
nuki coats sweet dr. Covino isn't
feeling well
oh that's his code Oh II know different
office of a for Stein
is it this one game reminds me of Irish
lycra with a different twist yeah
oh that's a bad thing stifling that
immersive sim spirit yeah
no entry yeah well how am I gonna enter
that way
answer me this sign just to make sure
yeah that all seems like there would be
a bridge or something that is a little
oh I found a guy yeah the music could
pop in before you even see the enemy
yeah that's a little yeah kind of kicks
it away all right
shotgun Oh whoo boy hey you guys key
card sweet but he got into his office
yeah wait how would out work I have this
sense this is cabin though I'm fortunate
okay give me the helmet back
it can't be okay
yes XE way like the periodic table yeah
okay uh where it is like a great secret
hidden code if they then have the
periodic table literally right next to
your note they'll never figure this out
except I can't
oh there's XE 54 54 wells yes yes or is
it se I don't remember
oh it's 3454 okay
okay so it's es not SC so it's 50 it's
something 54 I feel like everyone in
chat so it's right there how do you guys
not see it probably it's going to take
me a while here
Oh 99 there it is 9950 four okay
damnit
how's the game been reviewed yet no it
has not we should hopefully have a
review early next week
Tamar is working diligently on it I do
believe we will have you might have a
review in progress though yeah I think
by the end of the day ended today maybe
not in no no no tomorrow tomorrow but
tomorrow okay I was thinking today was
Friday
I wish saves Friday me too
but no tomorrow I am already getting
off-track yeah we need to find that
guy's body it's really easy to do that
in this game oh we're back where it told
us not to go no no head head should I go
back to his body yeah we need we want to
head to his body right yeah I just got
distracted
okay and then ya head through the back
door
right yes not remember man this is a
game I will get so long thin and I'll
just spend ten minutes in each room
exterior breach detected be honest is
breached hard vacuum no gravity there's
an exterior lock in the machine shop you
could use to reach him you'll have to
upgrade your suit with a propulsion
system first okay
so we need to find a propulsion thing
come on
so against body we need to find this
propulsion yeah ok let's try and laser
focusing on this yeah not get lost or
sidetracked
bring up the objective here all right
did they say this affects the PC has uh
what as far as the well so on the PC I
played I was playing it on a 1070 I
believe and I was able to fly it on max
settings ran great no framerate issues
at all I was a little underwhelmed at
how many graphical settings there were
there wasn't much in the way of others
are like field of view VOD type slide or
anything like that which is a little
bummer but
[Music]
I got electrocuted oh you're dead well
okay then alright it's like hmm how
could I get past you without getting
electrocuted and I get zapped and we ran
to put us I don't know yeah what's the
auto checkpoint in this game like it
doesn't seem too bad but it seems like
it can be kind of okay that's not too
bad that's something I mean I played on
PC so I'm just like that fiving
constantly yeah
yeah that's where he was hurt my fault
come we'll be on the charts and the
graphics don't look good I've been this
game looks great yeah I don't think it's
necessarily trying to look realistic no
no no but I it's got that it's just a
little dishonored ish not quite as
painted it's dishonored but it's kind of
going for that similar feel and I quite
like the way it looks that solve it ha
stupid
[Music]
no yes
all right oh oh I did not want to get
that out
whoa I don't know that that is insane
looking shoot him
not to take a lot of bullets
[Music]
[Music]
it's got explode yep it's like a party
you get a Ratchet and Clank jib all gun
not dead somebody wants to know if
there's much enemy variation so at the
beginning you shouldn't have the mimic
guys you have phantoms which are kind of
like make more humanoid looking ones and
then we got these robots you haven't
seen much more past that we do know
there's some like bigger crazy stuff
later there's this really big giant like
mini boss dude called the nightmare that
we are we actually put gameplay up of
that looks like pretty crazy yeah and
then the stun gun message kind of imply
there might be human enemies as well
which I'm kind of curious about what
he's more of you leave me alone
and a mimic to
dude you are at for hell I know you need
a ale
all right give me a break
I'll get this
try on the right oh okay well I guess
he's the GU gun yeah oh I wonder where
he is I use that on accident all the
time so my god
aim down sights and then it uses it so
is there no zoom at all for the gun
there is how do you do it you click the
stick and then you use upon the really
[Laughter]
well burned through lots of health packs
right there
man there's nothing repair level one
clearly there's a lot of stuff I found
in this game that's like level three
really early on it's like okay whoa no
dude get ready on back up
no thanks
okay I'll use the glue gun wait probably
need leverage three yep
all right
get all those materials underneath you
[Music]
so once I was the PC port good or did
the mouse movements feel like the
controller I found the control so great
on the PC I had no issues with mouse
movement at all it felt fine
you mask much with the fabricator yet I
have not but I think it now is the time
okay well we can make like some bullets
or something or a medkit probably bed
probably made bed kit for making that
case so ya go
Brad let's make some more I make more
med kits becoming keep it coming
all right make some bullets pull away
that's what we should be making
that's what they want this to make cool
sweet I'll eat a tomato jerky files we
got your Huntress bowl caster there's a
change log for the bull caster well I
updated my bolt caster sick well you
have fabrication plans now so you can
all you get you can get aim ammo for it
cool sick so wants to know what we can
compare this game to you so far and I
really sure you mean by that like System
Shock seems to be yeah dog Bioshock uh
very much a easy comparison those are
good games hey there's a doctor uh uh
quick save do we want to leave right now
it's gonna be a long loading screen or
should we stay here nice I go alright I
want to see I want to see the exterior
are you sure yes ah I don't have a
helmet though what if I just go out and
die well you know what I don't think
it's actually exterior although that'd
be cool maybe it is it's an exterior
talisman exterior yes see we're going to
go out for another 30 minutes or so so
feel free to hit us up with them
questions
so what says just getting more alien
power make people afraid of you in this
game isn't there some so like there is a
yeah so the when the devs were showing
it off yesterday on that livestream
there is a monster called the nightmare
that will show up and attack you
depending on how many alien powers you
have and the more alien patterns you
have the more frequently it'll show up
and if you have no alien powers it'll
never show up
well I regret getting that alien power
they imply there's like multiple tiers
like if you only have like the one alien
power it'll probably show up
we infrequently okay it's a cool idea uh
this person says I hope you can turn up
the F obeah fo v on pc said you cannot
unfortunately there is no echo be like
that
[Music]
all right
so says is it B are supported nope not
that I'm aware of
it's not actually a pretty fun one in VR
yeah so human corpse something and
that's where what see although we do
actually see a objective it's telling us
to go back in there okay
I'm not the doctor yeah let's head to
the human corpse prolly him
[Music]
locked walked did you unlock the
cosmonaut shotgun pack you did not I
didn't know I got it with my copy on PC
but no we cannot we do not have any fear
to show off
man I would like to be able to go faster
yeah a little slow there we go oh the
rest we'll never mind them review is
tomorrow not full review review in
progress should be up tomorrow the full
review will probably not be up until
early next week
this isn't dr. Calhoun oh I'm gonna
it's not it's just a baseball glove oh
man whole breach
wait wait there is it's that we miss
them why would they highlight a body
that only has a baseball club you really
want that baseball glove there's a
there's another corpse maybe they have a
bat well I'm gonna go for it
petri dish oh yeah get all that look at
that face little
okay there's a support 21 by 9 aspect
ratio good question do not know we have
some widescreen monitors in the office
so that might be something or ultra
widescreen I should say so that's maybe
something to test out yeah this game
would be cool with that
I agree I feel like stealth games like
Dishonored as well would like I didn't
try it with dishonored but I feel like
that would have been really cool
definitely benefit from it a little more
spatial awareness I keep thinking about
if I next time I get a monitor if I want
to get an ultra wide screen but then I
also think about all the things that
don't support ultra widescreen
yeah I want all that like black bar on
the side I don't know we got a safe here
did we found the doctor uh he is very
close by I'm just looting
got to get them shotgun shells he's up
there I think
there is I think that's him yep
boom thank you game not surprising I
think I won't be in for my shift
deliver lots of spare okay do you still
want me to finish this array i
fabricated a shit-ton eyeglass I don't
recall you asked me to set up a new
array you must have misunderstood are
you honestly I prefer if you left my
experiments alone in my absence
well look I have a message you left me
seriously I would not have made all this
if you hadn't no no of course let's just
dr. Tommy knows going off the defence
but some of that now but alright go back
inside so also what video card we're
using uh it's called a PlayStation 4
oh dang is this game worth its price
can't really say yet I mean not too far
in yeah this is where product two hours
in I really like it so far
me too the aiming is kind of janky on
console but other than that I've I like
I like the story so far I like the setup
somebody wants to know when the steam
version will be activated in Germany do
they have different time zones when they
unlock unstable India if it's if it's
okay if it's a worldwide Universal
unlock for everyone it will unlock at
about six hours is what it's going to
lock for us I do not know how steam does
it with different countries though so
yeah if it's different time for you
does this game give you give you a
feeling of dishonor - yeah it kind of
does definitely like player choice
immersive sim like what you were saying
earlier you can interact with anything
yep just about anything
Goemon I was like the alternative
history yeah the I always love it when
games or I mean anything kind of messes
with that
what happened if Kennedy didn't get shot
yeah giant space stations and aliens
apparently yeah seems plausible I think
I'm most excited to just mess around
with like the different abilities and
powers and but then those kinds are
going to attack you
that's true how about if they attack you
and you kill them you get sweet loot
from it
okay so there's an actual reason you can
also hide from them as well Oh
forgot about that ah well that was
merciless damn not even a warning Wow
okay so once it was scary it is I mean
that kind of gave me a little jump yeah
I mean I don't think it's scary like
unsettling it's more just like lots of
jump scares like you walk into a room
and think it's empty and things have
been pout at you stupid oh that works
okay that's how I got by the first time
all right
you there we go
quicks it
no it's saving automatically that's why
okay game was one step at a yeah
very atmospheric - just yeah
good music good lighting comfortable
going down the stairs apparently how
does this run on PC runs great I've had
no issues with it on PC I am playing on
a 1070 though so I mean I'm sure they
the devs have put up the minimum
hardware specs for that kind of stuff
make sure you got the right equipment
but yeah I mean I've had it as far as
like pitching or you know framerate
drops or bugs like nope didn't fun find
so far I should also say that I'm also
playing it at 1080 I'm not playing in a
bone I know oh yeah like with Dishonored
mean rob had issues where we would play
that 1080 would be fine but then we
would played above 1080 and then it
would start having weird issues even
though my computer could totally run it
yeah start freaking out so I haven't
tried at like 1440 yet I require that
you fabricate a travel mug that weighs
exactly 170 grams empty of course my
feeble hands need a lightweight
container for my coffee I'll be sure to
put put a good word to doctor phone
Steve gods whoever he's setting that
today god Calvino is dead that was me oh
it's more about it sure okay I'll do the
objective I'm getting distracted so
easily there's like everything just like
piques my interest in like oh what's
this like do it lay back no just one who
could not connect I could knock on
Network go to network utilities of
course
okay
we can check all of them online
maybe I just run Diagnostics is yeah
maybe that's maybe as probably that one
1496 last one of course yeah
[ __ ] I don't want to it's important
you're the rest of it listen you've got
to go back to your office
hey I wasn't I won't watch these yeah
[Music]
yeah what cool tech I know light bill
capture looks a little hot
where's the photometer the handheld oh
did you take it no oh yeah yesterday we
had to now I can't find one we've only
ever had one nonsense
I guess you forgot well let's check out
to
question where the game do I find my
printer stuff the game pops of a message
that tells you you'll be able to find it
in your office we were done takes you
back to our 45 to or 45 minutes to an
hour depending on depending on how no in
the environment everything I suppose
it's it's late after all go go asleep
what about you what about me yeah I
don't concern yourself
I'll finish right I guess I'll see you
later then
yeah you lip-sync fall off there yeah
you're always saying I guess that worked
I guess I'll see you later I guess
you're a scientist stop guessing this
guy is an [ __ ] or be quiet [ __ ] look
at that eyebrows hey don't be scuffling
dick yeah for real okay we're going back
to the room I can drop off yeah all of
my gym now I'll be a good place to end
it - yeah watch the rest the video or
however much they allow phantom should
we go about dealing with this I have
more gonna use some more of these neuro
mods yeah
I've to some reason I thought I had more
never mind
well I mean I guess I couldn't Gaddis
effectiveness of medkits that's kind of
temp that's pretty good all right
someone says these video modules are
cool but can access GameSpot on YouTube
watch our YouTube videos like that watch
lobby and you can actually see like the
device cool
yeah but then you'd see like slightly to
the left we have like a pile of cables
yeah
looks like a mess and I throw this out
on to that well but I got a thing whoa
did your help
nice okay he'll Oh someone says we
missed the doctor using a secret door on
the video oh let's go back you better
not be messing with us Cory I'm in the
wrong I'm in the wrong room
I don't know secrets at the second video
I don't know it's probably the second
video he doesn't leave though you're
leaving unless they're out time at the
other dock I thought we were done you
know just just turn it off then I feel
like you're upset with me no uh-uh
what's not it's computers it's it's late
after all go go it's not okay
what about you what about me yeah I
don't concern yourself
I'll finish right I guess I'll see you
later then yeah you guess what
you're always saying I guess that worked
I guess I'll see you later
I don't know watch the secured now if
it's not there yes II know watch or be
quiet
watch her leader that's maybe good night
dr. Kelvin I'll check the other hmm
you know scuff on it
is it the first video the first video oh
oh yeah yeah yeah he just moved yeah we
left too early
okay
oh that's why you saying you wanted a
mug that weight exactly that many pounds
yeah interesting how did this guy know
about it though
[Music]
well we need to find out huh this game's
cool about that thermos oh yeah it's
tumblers that's really cool super cool
oh that's rad look at two neuro mods and
he's his card thank you for that tip yes
Thank You Calvin or not Calvin Cory was
about to say maybe it's him in the chat
dr. Calvin yeah exactly
his spirit lives on oh I'm staying away
from there I want to die right that was
awesome that was really cool really I'm
really glad we got to see that now I'm
gonna be I'm gonna feel like if I know
how's that it's gonna take me so long to
finish this game now oh boy oh [ __ ]
gonna run
there's still so much more I wanted to
explore in that no we playing on the pro
no we're playing on any standard ps4
ever since the pro came out it's
everyone's favorite question it does at
Pro Sport yeah Pro supports Pro we got
pros in the office I guess we could find
out
unfortunately this took long enough to
install as is actually installed really
really quickly on Steam yeah Erin said
it took him like ten minutes took me
yeah
five hours yeah I got in at nine
finished it too is you give the good
Internet plugged in dope cuz I have a
yeah I have like two cables ones like
the okay Internet ones they're really
good internet it was but it I don't know
ps4 downloads for like they take longer
than Xbox one for me like people say
Xbox one is always really slow but I
think ps4 takes ps4 is probably the
slowest in my experience I don't
download Xbox at many that's true yeah I
don't do it that often I'd it but I
remember downloading forts of horizon 3
which was a pretty big game and that was
like 40 minutes I think Chris wants to
know how did Cory know that that's a
good question yeah that's what I was
wondering too did you know that Cory
actually I mean people have been
streaming this game you kind of probably
probably saw it that's that's so cool
though yeah
someone wants to know if somebody if
somebody has leaked the endings they
just want to know how many there are
I have no idea if there are multiple
presumably if this game is in the spirit
of immersive Sims there would be
multiple endings hey buddy
oh there's the second one I'm [ __ ]
9:00 a.m. not gunmen I'll say your help
[Applause]
whoa oh boy run [ __ ]
[Music]
got him I don't think so
now did you guys yes I did
wasted a lot of ammo and health packs
though okay so she's not waste shotgun
rounds on this thing all right
this thing is a different color Oh oh
yeah it's got a purple one definitely
take some more damage killed it a guy
you damn okay let's uh let's try and get
through these guys quick I want to I
want to get to that office yeah uh yeah
the game actually comes out tomorrow
we just got early copies yep or tonight
maybe tonight well for us we're on the
Pacific coast
so we stuff a locks with deadly force I
shine which is a midnight on the East
Coast
can't say as far as uh how other
countries do it I'm afraid to go back in
here John Luke though yes you have to go
through here no but I feel like I have
these guys are not messing around I'm
gonna be no good
all right and just shocked and just go
right for it
thanks so much help
[Music]
nice last one I could have sworn we saw
- there wasn't there was - I thought
there was two as well I mean a quick
save again good call
okay it's this thing right
what was that the thing that was oh
maybe there it is
oh that did a lot of damage nice our
resident counselor dr. pol would like to
encourage anyone experiencing symptoms
of disturbed sleep
chronic stress or anxiety to schedule an
appointment in Spanish Oh No dead again
well that's why I quick say yeah at
least a quick saved yeah they told me to
just run these are a lot tougher than
before mm-hmm more aggressive for sure
wonder if there's a story reason for
that yeah I'm curious why they just got
so much harder
I know you're coming come on can't fool
me old turret yeah buddy here you pick
it up
shoot it do you it's a disabled to pick
it up it's dad
so when you pick it up it does not use
any value uh so to put it down and then
you have to deploy it again well any of
them any others come okay here we are
we're back this room my video is now and
if I watch one Oh Shiva went in my name
is uh oh I think it's gonna get fair
yeah okay good it's gonna say I have to
say you have to destroy Talos 1 the
research the Typhon nothing can survive
including you I know how it sounds but
you've seen with those creatures okay
from the very beginning there a party
gotta kill yourself if even drugs cell
gets back to earth we're lost
I'm sorry I wish there was another way
January can walk you through activating
the self-destruct mechanism Alex will
try to stop you he's allergic to failure
she proud Oh doctor mom and dad with his
tail between legs oops
so it's up to you now good luck
told you you wouldn't like it
[Music]
all right I think that's a pity gap lock
to call it right thank I agree that was
fun yeah I want to immediately keep
playing this game you too
I want to play more unfortunately I
can't edit thanks yeah that's the thing
yeah a little busy so thank you everyone
for watching the game comes out tomorrow
we're going to have a review in progress
up later later tomorrow for you guys to
check out and then we should have the
full review hopefully sometime early
next week not sure when Tamar is I'm
sure playing and working on that
diligently but we'll have plenty of
other coverage about prey and all things
video games so stay tuned game spot
thanks guys
yeah thank you